hello everyone and welcome to a very
important game from round nine over 2013
candidates tournament it's a game
between what male Kramnik and magnus
carlsen and at the time this game was
played that this was one of the games
everyone wanted to see
well Carlsen R&L was also in the
previous round again one of the games
everyone wanted to see because two of
them were good the current leader sent a
tournament but at the time this game was
played Latimer Kramnik was a world
number two regarding ratings and Magnus
Carlsen was a world number one but even
though they were world number one and
number two the difference in rating
between them was I believe almost almost
70 rating points so quite a quite a gap
and before we see this game we do have a
couple of photos from this round so
let's check them out here we have a nice
photo of Carlsen and then we have a nice
photo of the playing grounds their
scores and kramnik on the right and on
the left there's there's gate fund and
eleven Iranian so next we have also a
nice close-up of Carlsen with Peter
Dodgers in the back another close up of
course and and here we have a photo of
the two of them after a couple of
opening moves have been played caution
which is usual as you've stated in the
comments
orange juice plus water mix and he's
staring at Kramnik for some reason but
okay let's see this game so romney has
the white pieces and if you if you've
seen in I believe it was in round two in
round one he face Levon Aronian in round
two he faced Kramnik where Carson had
white pieces I was a very theoretical
draw and a very tough game and now cross
and faces Kramnik with the black pieces
so definitely not an easy task
chronic opens with d4 Knight to f6 we
have c4 e6 and the g3 Cromley goes for
his standard Catalan d5 Bishop to g2
Bishop to e7 Knight to f3
we have castles castles and D captures
on c4 and the Knight to e5 Knight to e5
an interesting move not allowing this
bishop to to be developed via
possibility 7 then b7 would be a target
and also it seems like Knight to c6 is
not possible because
than both Knight and Bishop are covering
the c6 square but this is in fact what
calls in place and this is in fact the
strongest move that allows black to gain
the most activity so chess is sometimes
funny like this here Bishop captures on
c6 was played also possible of course is
Knight captures on c6 but after a pawn
captures and Bishop captures rook to b8
black will get a bit more activity than
then in the variation a Cromley decided
to play so we have Bishop captures on c6
Bishop captures and the knife captures
temporarily given up the bishop pair but
as the Queen and Bishop are attacked
black will also be deprived of the
bishop pair so Queen to e8 Knight
captures 97 this comes with check we
have Queen captures on e7 and now comes
Queen to c2 Queen to c2 is actually a
variation Kramnik prepared two years ago
in 2011 for his game against a job of in
Kazan but he never got to play it he
says that in the last moment he decided
to play something else
so here cross in place he 5 and we have
rook to d1 this Queen to c2 rook to d1
this was his idea that he prepared two
years ago to play against her job of
this ePHI comes with the idea that if
Queen captures in c4 then after he
captures on d4 then the Queen is now
attacking e too so if Queen captures
then Queen captures I need to so instead
we have looked at the one by Kramnik and
now comes rope to b8 and Knight to c3 h6
by Carlsen D captures on e5 Queen
captures on e5 and Bishop to f4 now
attacking the Queen Queen back to e7 and
here you do have to you don't have to
play something and you could play
something like Knights to d5 perhaps it
seems like and I said you have to bring
a rope to d5 then double up rooks rooks
on the D file but black is definitely
interested in playing Queen to before
and start an attack against this B to
pawn so yeah if you did something like
this captures captures yes you would be
kind of preparing to double up on the D
file but after Bishop here rock moves
then definitely Queen to b4 is coming
and now you either have to move
roll back or play a passive more like
group to be one not something chronic is
interested in doing so after Queen to e7
rook to d4 rook to d4 a very nice idea
now Queen to b4 will actually be met by
Knight to f4
now the beat pawn is defended and also
there is an open attack from the from
the roof to the c4 pawn and if Bishop to
d7 is played then we have a very nice
variation of rook captures on c4 but
should capture Sunday for and now b3
about the the bishop and the Queen are
attacked so Bishop capture some b3
giving back the piece pawn captures and
now Queen captures on b3 and after rook
captures an a7 white would definitely
win this c7 point at some point and
enjoy a very nice extra point
so after this rook to d4 we have Bishop
to e6 by crossing defending the c4 pawn
and the c4 pawn although it's a double
point it's a very nice pawn because it
prevents a white from pushing the beep
on and the B to pawn remains a weakness
so rook a to d1 a chroma key doubles up
on the D file rook to b6 and Queen to d2
now we have King to h7 f3 rook F to b8
doubling up on the B file and now really
going for that B to pawn queen to e3 and
a very nice move Queen to e3 you you're
giving up the b2 point and there's a
really no better move for black black
black really has to grab that point the
idea is that rook captures on c4 is
coming and since the bishop is pinned at
the Queen on e7 is undefended and you
can't really move the Queen to kind of
prepare recapture some b2 because then
Bishop captures on c7 would be a threat
the Queen also has to keep guarding this
point so Carson is Carson is in a very
difficult situation here so rook
captures on b2
we have rook captures on c4 now going
for the c7 pawn and rook back to b7
we have rook to a for attacking the a 7
point and now comes Luke to e a rook to
e8 was also an idea kind of a passive
move for the Brooke so Carlsen decides
to go for the active defense rook to e8
we have rook captures on a7 rook
captures Queen captures and now comes
Queen to b4 attacking
the night and knight on c3 and here
chronic chronic didn't spend all that
much time he has a couple of options
here as you don't really have a good
square to move the night you definitely
want to defend it you either wanna
defend it with Queen D for Queen III
Bishop to d3 Bishop to d2 is an idea
although you're moving the bishop back
not really something you want to do you
know reduce activity of your pieces and
the real idea is actually Queen to d4
and after something like c5 either for
single trade or forcing White Queen to
move let's say Queen d2 now comes King
to g8
getting the King out of any possible
checks from this diagonal and rook to a1
and now white would be able to start
pushing his pawn and this would this
would have been the best idea for white
but here kramnik decided to play Bishop
to e5
so defending the knight this way and
crossing plays Knight to d5 and here
chronic started thinking and chronic was
thinking for almost half an hour
I believe it's 26 minutes or something
but he definitely didn't consider this
move and what do you do here well you
are you have to capture the night you
you don't really have any other good
moves
so Knight captures we have Bishop
capture Sun d5 and now Queen captures on
c7 chronic chronic grabs the pawn and
the idea is that Carson doesn't have the
option of capturing the a to pawn
why why is this of course I believe
everyone can see at the after Bishop
captures then Queen to c2 checks the
king and of course wins the bishop here
so Queen c2 check King moves and I
simply capture the bishop and white wins
the game
so okay oh it seems black and black can
capture this but still it would be rook
in Queen yeah with an extra pawn it
would be a winning position for white
kinda missed this but yeah even after
even after black captures
let me just check this what's what's the
idea here yeah if you capture if you
capture Queen C for was played in the
game but if you capture yeah I mean I
immediately saw that Quincy to check
check the king and
but after you move the King Danya Queen
captures rook captures okay you're only
up upon but it's a queen and rook and up
upon so what what should be able to pull
this to win but okay
anyway after Queen to c7 Queen to c4 was
played now offering a trade of Queens we
have a 3 and a 3 kramnik did have the
option of pushing efore immediately for
example efore now forcing the bush back
Bishop 3 6 and did not rate Queens after
captures captures now the rock is still
attacking this Bishop but at least you
don't have upon un'ytu so the bishop can
move and have free Bishop to d6 white
black would capture upon here and now
you're still up upon but it's a rook and
opposite colored bishop it's hard to say
if you can actually push this to a win
so chronic had a different idea after
Queen to see for a chronic played a3 he
decided he he'd rather give up the de to
pawn than the past a pawn so okay we had
f6 kicking the bishop Queen captures on
c4 Bishop captures and now Bishop the c3
rook captures an e2 rook to d4 attacking
the bishop bishop tafe Bishop to b5 and
now Bishop to b4 so as you can see it
will be very hard for whites to actually
push this a pawn rook to e3 attacking
the f3 pawn king f2 rogue back to e2
which check King g1 rook back to e3
we have f4 now King back to e2 rock to
d6 rook to c2
we have g4 Bishop to c6 now going for
some rope to G - checking ideas Bishop
to d2 blocking the rook Bishop to f3
attacking the pawn on g4 h 3 defending
rook to a2
with a Bishop to b4 rook to g2 this
comes with check team to f1 and now rook
to h2 attacking the h3 pawn and it was
in this position that the players agreed
to a draw as it is a pawn up for
Vladimir Kramnik but they reach the move
40 so time control has been reached this
is move 41 and so it would be very hard
to do too
to really do anything here so so so they
decided if black pursues this goes for
this rook after Sun h3 then then rook to
d7 Bishop to f8 will be an idea and
white will white will win window pawns
on the Kings side and in chronic chronic
doesn't think he can do anything here so
yeah a very nice game between world
number one and world number two I do
hope you enjoyed it and yeah it's
interesting that chronic saved that
variation Queen c2 Rugby one he prepared
the hell for a job of he prepared it two
years ago but it's only now that he used
it so Carson really did run run into
some heavy preparation but he was able
to solve all the problems over the board
even though he hasn't seen this
variation but you are welcome to check
out the interview which the two of them
from the press conference after the game
I will put a link in the description
below as usual you can also check out
some more photos from around nine also
doing will be in the description below
so yeah that's it I would like to thank
Mitchell Bogart Paul Daniel is in Atlas
easier Nafis al-abbas and Danny
McCullough for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see soon as we will
check out two more games from round 9 of
the 2013 candidates tournament and I saw
that Paul Deadpool 2 and Avengers
infinity war yesterday and you know I
was actually really enjoyed the infinity
war it was much better than I expected
and you know I had no expectations of
Deadpool 2 so that so I just watched it
but yeah just just wanted to put that
out there so I think you'll and I will
see you soon